[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERICA HANSON: I'm really excited
that sub-Saharan Africa now
has the Developer Student
Club program here,
with 60 leaders trying to solve
their problem using technology.
DAVID ASEM: DSC you
gives you an opportunity
to learn web and mobile
development skills,
to be exposed to
new technologies.
ANIEDI UDO-OBONG: Leading
a developer student club
is an awesome opportunity.
There are lots of resources
that you get connected to.
You're interacting
with businesses.
with real people,
helping provide solutions for
people who actually need them.
SHINGIRAI MARANDURE: It's
been going great so far.
I'm meeting people
that share my vision
and bringing technology
and new languages that we
have in programming to Africa.
LUM-NEH ANGELA: One of
the biggest takeaways
has been the talk on how
to be a persuasive leader
and how to build a community.
Also, in terms of
the technical skills,
exploring, and
seeing how I could
switch to using TensorFlow
for machine learning.
JULIET EHIMUAN:
Congratulations to you
guys for being our
developer-student leads.
You're a very special group.
You are the future.
WILLIAM FLORANCE: It's exciting
to listen to the students
tell us how they're
identifying and trying to solve
the problems of Africa.
SOLOMON AWOSUPIN:
What a great event.
There's so much passion,
so much interest.
I'm super optimistic
about what it's
going to become in
the next few years.
SEGUN OLUMIDE: It's a
really good opportunity
for you to come and
learn, collaborate.
JANE ODUM: I'm going to be
able to impart knowledge
when I go back to school to
leverage on this platform
and become a better developer.
SHINGIRAI MARANDURE: It
is our responsibility
to bring that interest and
vibe in Android Development.
You don't need to be
an expert in coding.
You just need to be there with
your passion and commitment.
And we can make this
world a better place.
CROWD: [INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]